two x plus five equals 13 is an example
of a linear equation in one variable
it's linear as the degree of the
polynomial is 1 and if you plot the
graph of this equation you will get a
straight line if it was 2x plus 5y you
would call it a linear equation in two
variables anyway how do we solve such
equations generally there are two ways
in which you can get to the value of x
in this example for instance some would
first subtract 5 from both sides
that would give us 2x plus 5 minus 5
equals 13 minus 5 5 cancels out on the
left and we are left with 2x equals 8
dividing both sides by 2 we get the
value of x as 4 so first we eliminated
the 5 and then the 2 though it was a
very logical way to go about it it may
prove to be a bit lengthy for your
competitive exams the transpose method
gets you to the answer a bit faster to
have just X on the left hand side we
first transpose 5 to the other side plus
when transposed to the other side
becomes a minus transposing 5 to the
other side gives us 2x equals 13 minus 5
and 13 minus 5 is 8 to eliminate the -
we need to transpose it to the other
side we get X is equal to 8 by 2 which
is 4 if you look at them closely both
methods are actually the same just that
the transpose method saves you some time
if you wish to get a deeper
understanding of solving linear
equations do have a look at our
background tutorials based on it
meanwhile let's try solving a couple of
linear equations how do we solve for the
value of y as we need just Y on the left
hand side let's transpose 7 to the other
side first we get Y by 5
12 minus 7 which is 5 now transposing
this 5 in the denominator to the
right-hand side we get the value of y as
5 times 5 25 pause the video and try
solving the second example on your own
as we need to find the value of a let's
try getting all terms with a on the
left-hand side and we can simultaneously
transpose 6 to the other side we get 2a
minus a over 2 on the left-hand side and
6 when transposed to the right becomes
minus 6 to a minus a over 2 gives us 3 a
over 2 transposing 3 & 2 to the right we
get the value of a as minus 4 so solving
linear equations is easy and using the
transpose method gets you to the answer
quicker